one of my old bosses I used to work I
was the crib director at vaynermedia so
Gary Vaynerchuk was like my boss
essentially what's up Sam and we have a
guest
Mike Cesario welcome welcome to the
podcast
thanks guys there's a lot of crazy stuff
going on right now this well we'll have
this hour to be a little bit of an
escape we talked about everything going
on last podcast I think let's we'll try
to make this like just say at least a 45
minute 50 minute escape for people we
could kind of talk about yeah exactly
it does kind of feel silly to be like oh
here's some business ideas when like you
know the whole world is it's really you
know you know tilt whether it's true
coronavirus or the different protests
that are going on but like you said I
think you know for me I'm like glued to
Twitter and the muse and all this stuff
all day then you know by 7 8 p.m. I just
need a break I go walk my dog and I go
listen to some mindless stuff about
sports or whatever else just you know
just to calm my mind and so hopefully we
could be that for some people we're a
bit of a diversion or a bit of an escape
from the heaviness that's going on so
you know Mike I'm glad you're here we
you have a product that we've talked
about on the podcast before which is
liquid death so if somebody doesn't know
what liquid death has given the what is
liquid death and then we're gonna talk
about how you started that and then
we're gonna brainstorm some cool ideas
and spaces around around what did you do
sure so I mean I guess at the heart of
what liquid death really is we're really
just completely trying to change the way
healthy food and beverages are marketed
at the end of the day most of the most
hilarious memorable ad campaigns that
you ask most people about it the last 10
years they'll tell you Bud Light don't
know SEC East
Snickers Doritos skittles like all junk
food and alcohol that's the funniest
most memorable kind of youth culture
owning and energy drinks like Red Bull
that's like let's not leave old spice
out well it's not really a food or
beverage but but yeah it's like all it's
all junk food and alcohol that does all
the
Escalus youth culture marketing whereas
healthy food is traditionally marketed
to like mom and it's quiet and it's
responsible or it's like look better
where you know show you you know fitness
models you know drinking bottles of
water like it's a very different they
don't use fun to market whereas
unhealthy beverages stuff like that like
they want to own fun
so we're basically doing that with water
so we want to be able to take the
healthiest thing you can drink that most
people don't drink enough of and brand
it and build you know a cool you know
thing around it where it's something
that you feel totally comfortable
drinking a liquid death in a bar or at a
house party right at a music festival or
at work or in the gym and just making it
more fun to walk around and have a lot
right and that's you definitely made
headlines when you raised all that money
cuz everyone was like this is such a
silly idea and they raised all this
money I didn't it's a stupid reason I
mean it was it seemed like an awesome
company and totally worthy of going big
but so it kind of worked
right like you you definitely uh you
definitely ruffled some feathers and I
think that's good no yeah I think you
know I always bring up I one of the you
know I listen to the Reid Hoffman
podcast a lot master scale yeah and it's
like I loved it he always pushes he's
like truly innovative ideas are almost
comical at first because if it seems
like it makes a lot of sense right now
it probably means there's four other
companies that have been working on it
for five years already it's like the
things that are truly unique and
innovative like almost don't make any
sense at first or seem laughable and I
think like that's kind of the case of
liquid death I think it's like we're
really trying to disrupt a category in a
way that's not just disruption for the
sake of disruption you know I think it's
like we strongly believe that and I
don't think it's something hard to
understand you know in a category where
almost all the products themselves are
perceived as the same you know people
are assuming I only drink Fiji because
it's got 0.75 more electrolytes than
smart water which has 0.5 the pH is 7
point 7 said said
it's like most people assume water is
the same it's more of a brand play and
we believe if we can make you laugh we
have a way better chance that you giving
us your dollar 69 then the faceless
brand next to us who's trying to shout
at you electrolyte so let you know
they're like guys this all seems like
snake oil to me like I feel like there's
real human beings behind liquid depth
and I'd want to have a beer with so I'd
rather give you my dollar 60 grand and
let's talk a little bit about the form
factor so is it's a it's a tall cam as
what I've seen are there other form
factors or no no it's just the talking
it's all kin which is cool the branding
of it is sort of like you know almost
like heavy metal or punk rock how do you
describe yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah I
think at the end of the day you would
you would say we're like alternative
punk metal inspired design and and vibe
I think the way I like to think about
our brand is like we're a professional
wrestler like it's all theater and fun
and everyone thinks it's trying to be
real like no one thinks the Undertaker
is really an evil guy from the dead who
likes metal no it's a character and it's
fun to like buy a character yeah and
that's kind of that's how we think about
it like we're just playing this fun
sorry second
we're just playing this fun character
it's fun to choose to believe that yeah
this is what it is and not take it too
seriously and you write like you know if
you're at a bar or a music festival and
you choose water you feel like you're
choosing you're opting out of the fun
and in fact they'll sort of you know
it'll make you feel that way you know
you'll get the small plastic rinky-dink
Cup with a baby straw right versus if
you ordered a you know alcoholic drink
or something else it's kind of that's
actually a good point I mean I don't
drink and I still go to bars and I
always felt like I used to order sprites
with lime in it because I was like looks
like a gin and tonic yeah my god one
being people feel uncomfortable what so
I'll just even though I don't like to
drink soda like I'll drink it anyway and
I don't have an O'Doul's because I'm
like uh then everyone's just kind of
like it's just gonna come up and so it's
it is a great alternative to that and so
Mike I'm curious where does this idea
come from
so I think this was really just like a
culmination of all my passions and
experience sort of like converged into
one you know it's like I grew up in high
school playing in punk rock and metal
bands and skateboarding and you know I
would do all the show flyers and album
art and stuff for our bands which kind
of got like the entrepreneurial probably
side of things cuz like you know we're
booking shows and we're selling merch
and like we're pressing records and
doing all that kind of stuff then I got
into a career of like graphic design
which led into advertising so then I was
like an advertising creative director
for a long time and I worked on big
brands like Nestle and Toyota and
Volkswagen and Naked Juice and all this
kind of stuff so I think I got a good
sense of where I think big companies
screw up I guess like where I think
they're short-sighted like I can't tell
you how many boardrooms I've been in
where I'm trying to convince people that
social media isn't some like niche
little thing you add on to your business
like it is the Internet when you say I'm
going on the Internet nine times out of
10 you're going on social media you know
it's like I think a lot of brands are
just way behind the ball to understand
what it really takes to be successful in
the social environment like your little
social posts aren't just competing
against other beverages you're competing
against influencers who are uncensored
and can do crate easy on the wall stuff
you're again trash you're competing
against everything awesome on the
internet when you're scrolling through
your feed that's what your marketing is
competing against so when you really
think about it that way do you really
think your little ad that seems like a
typical beverage thing is gonna actually
stand out in someone's quick scrolling
feed amongst all this other amazing
stuff probably not so I think the bar
for what stuff needs to be is way higher
and I think that's what I built liquid
death around like we think about
marketing like entertainment I don't
ever want to put something in your feed
that feels like marketing I wanted to
feel like actual entertainment that made
you laugh or it was the funniest thing
that you may
be stall that morning that you want to
share with your friends or whatever that
like we're never just sticking marketing
in your face like it's always going to
entertain you or it's gonna do something
of value that it gives you I've got a
question
I'm gonna check Sam I'm looking at their
Facebook ads right now and what you're
saying is true so here's the two ads I
see I wish I could show this through a
podcast so I'm gonna show this to your
ears but there's a giant can of liquid
death in front of a mountain and says
this is dumb don't buy this there's
another one that's like I don't know
what you'd call this it's like a it's
like the mountain from Game of Thrones
but instead of his head is a can
a liquid death erupting from his
muscular body and he's standing in a
grocery store aisle grocery store aisle
holding an axe and it just says like
this is a bill nationwide in Whole Foods
I'm gonna I want to ask a question about
that but first is there any indication
is there anything you can give me the
shows or the listeners how big this
business is like what what what size you
guys are yeah why should we why should
we care about what you say is the other
thing or not I want you to like impress
people yeah I mean I can't get into like
specific kind of sales numbers but since
we launched national and Whole Foods
basically we launched the day the
pandemic started so we what we went into
Whole Foods March 15 and basically even
even though we've been in a pandemic
where they've had like 80% decreased
store traffic and everything else going
on we've had insane growth in Whole
Foods and we're now the fastest growing
water bread in Whole Foods right and
you've raised like how much money to
make the safari grand total since the
very beginning of everything I think
we've raised around 12 total right now
so great ok so we kind of have an idea a
little bit about sizing when you look at
when you are looking at this business
and what and what to start was that your
perspective which is what is something
that I mean it sounds like you're into
health and in that type of stuff what is
something that is like good for you but
has [__] marketing and how can I build a
business around that was that your
perspective in a nutshell I think it
really came from you know you know where
I grew up playing in punk bands and and
metal bands and stuff like that I was
still and a lot of my friends in that
world we're very much into health like I
was a vegetarian at age 16 a lot of my
friends in that scene were more my
friends were even vegan a lot of them
like you know didn't drink alcohol I do
and I think that's one thing that we've
been like misbranded is like liquid
death its water for the straightedge
crowd that is not what we're trying to
do I think it's something that's been
adopted by them for you know the reasons
of yeah it is more fun to walk around in
a bar if you don't want
drink than something like this but I
think another thing that the health food
industry does I don't think we want to
do is we don't want to be preachy to
people we don't want to say you should
be doing this and I shouldn't be
drinking this and you shouldn't be doing
that like we're like hey you want to go
rip some shots in a bar fine but maybe
take a break and have a water for an
hour you know or like hey you want to
smoke weed or whatever it's like great
like maybe hydrate while you're doing it
right even if like hey you want to go
buy a monster energy drink or whatever
great maybe buy water too and have a
water after you just pound a bunch of
sugar I'm happy that's the good news
anybody who does any lifestyle also
drinks water and spray compared to any
lifestyle that you want it sounds like
you guys trying to do that let me ask
you like you've said some kind of
abstract ways like you know we felt this
was missing about what but I want you to
like rewind and make it real so like
take us back to the moment you have the
idea what's going on where are you where
does the idea come from who are you
talking to and then like how did it turn
into something sure so as as you know in
the world of rock and roll punk metal
whatever the only brands that have
invested in trying to own that culture
have been energy drinks primarily
Monster so Monster was sponsoring the
Vans Warped Tour with all the punk bands
they sponsor all these different metal
bands like you don't see that with many
other brand doing that now so I
graduated high school in 2000 so that's
what I think you're really starting to
see that swell up and a lot of my
friends were in bands we were at the
Vans Warped Tour that was sponsored by
monster back in I think it was like
around 2007 somewhere around there I was
in Denver working for an agency there
went and hung out at the work toward
with my friends you know they took me
backstage we're hanging out with like
all the bands you know the bands tour
buses and I saw that they had like huge
stacks of monster that these guys are
all drinking and I was like how are you
guys pounding energy drinks right now
like in the hot Sun like it's like 98
degrees and they're like no dude it's
water and
was like monster gives all the bands
they look like monster cancer at the
bottom it says tour water because they
know that none of these bands are gonna
drink this stuff in the Sun so bands on
stage are pounding what looked like
energy drinks to all these kids but it's
really just water that's what I remember
thinking like that's so [__] up like
you know like you know and I think that
was the moment where I where it kind of
started me down the path of Oh like why
is it stuff like water like marketed in
a cool way like this and it was like
when you actually had a freezing cold
can of water it's just more refreshing
to you psychologically right there's
actually a popular science I think it
was they did a study where they showed
that temperature was the number one
quencher of thirst neurologically which
is why like if you're really thirsty and
you suck on an ice cube it actually kind
of quenches your thirst a little bit
even though no water is actually
absorbing into your body right so I
think there was just like that was sort
of the aha moment for me where I started
thinking about why isn't it healthier
things because none of us none of my
friends hang out one to actually drink
energy drinks like we just wanted to
drink water or beer you know but it's
like of course you're banned you got to
make money you're touring so of course
you got to take the checks from these
companies and and you know they they
they play ball to a certain extent but
that's where I think the idea really
started and what other verticals did you
explore that you think would also work
for this did you explore any other
products that you think like so it's
definitely there's definitely
opportunity here if you do what we're
doing but in this this thing or that
thing so 21x so that so that worked or
thing happened
yeah like around 2007-2008 where I
started thinking about that but then it
was a couple like maybe two years later
I was living in San Francisco and I
actually developed the spirits brand on
my own called Western grace and it was
basically brandy so it was like hey how
do we make brandy cool because I had
brandy it was
why don't people drink more it's just
like whiskey without the bird but every
brandy bottle literally in the in the
liquor store had dust on it it was like
what your grandfather drank or some
trying to be replica of French luxury
with cursive golden text on the bottle
but it was more similar per taste
profile wise to a whiskey which was the
biggest fastest growing spirit so I had
this idea to create a brandy that felt
more like a whiskey and felt cool and
sure enough like I found a brandy
distillery in Northern California who
were like oh my god we've been waiting
for someone to try to make brandy like
mass and cool for like 20 years so they
were like hey we'll make the brandy for
you then I went and found some spirit
industry folks who helped create Hendrix
Jain and Sailor Jerry rum to kind of
come on board they thought it was really
interesting and then all of a sudden we
have a brandy company and I moved back
to my hometown of Philadelphia where my
partners were and we basically like I
was only a couple years out of AD school
no entrepreneurial experience no liquor
industry experience and we started
building this brandy company and it's
still around today there in probably 80
bars in LA they're all over Austin
they're in Nashville they're Florida but
I left the brand a little bit early on
because I just me and our spirits folks
we brought in kind of like didn't see
eye to eye on a couple things from a
marketing level so I said hey you guys
keep growing it from here I'm gonna kind
of go do my own thing and you know I'll
keep my little chunk of vested equity
and best of luck to you guys like no
hard feelings I'm sure you'll do great
with it and then went to work for an
agency in Tennessee that a friend of
mine started called human eye where I
started doing a bunch of well human eye
and eye we did a bunch of funny work for
the organic world we did this campaign
called save the bras the first organic
protein shake and we did this funny
viral video that just went bananas and
it was like the first time that like
humor had really been done like in the
world of organic and that was like the
reinforcement
the warp tour thing where it's like
right like why aren't more health brands
like playing with the kind of humor and
irreverent internet stuff that these
other you know unhealthy things are
doing and then that's really where I
started building the nuts and bolts of
liquid death and figuring out the
production and coming up with the
branding and then it was I think maybe
two years after that was when we
officially kind of launched it that's
that's pretty cool
do you do you think that there's still
opportunity for that I mean because when
you go to 7-eleven I mean I live in San
Francisco I'm in Austin right now
there's 7-elevens everywhere is and it's
only muscle milk is the only that's the
only protein based drink and that is
similar to your analogy of like a net
that's like an Evian or a Fiji or
something like a mass brand well if I'm
if I'm not wrong I think it'd be more
like taking cottage cheese and making
cottage cheese fun than it is Muscle
Milk or the kind of protein shakes which
are already kind of like trying to mass
market and get in with a sort of
different lifestyles whereas you know
some random product category where it is
only trying to play it safe non
internet-based marketing those are the
ones that you're talking about right
Mike where you think those have the sort
of larger Delta between what's out there
and what could be out there yeah I want
to hear which which of which if there
are any others that do have that Delta
that's what I'm getting at yeah it's
tricky and I think that's where it's a
so protein shake let's use that as an
example protein shakes if you think
about who the protein shake consumer is
probably predominantly male like dude
strike you know bulking up a lot of the
time you know at least in that world and
that's why organic valley when they came
to the agency they knew that like all
the ads they've been running cuz most of
all organic Valley's products are milk
and cheese and stuff that they sell at
Whole Foods all their commercials are
like picturesque sunsets over family
farms and our family farmers they just
care more than anyone but they knew that
when they launched an organic protein
shake it's a very different customer
than the mom who shot
Whole Foods through their other products
so they wanted us to come in and say hey
we know that it's like a muscle dude
that we're selling this to who's
typically not in organic you know the
big-time organic shopper maybe they are
buying two tubs of you know protein
powder at GNC or they're buying you know
muscle milk so they're like we still
want to appeal to that audience with
this very you know a protein shake
that's made by family farmers so we did
this whole funny video that's like you
know if Bros liked all the chemical
crazy [__] that's in protein shakes
if bros keep drinking them they might
not last much longer and they'll go
extinct and like who's gonna bring the
beer pong table when they're gone and
like you know like this whole idea of
like save a bro get them on an organic
protein ship that was sort of like the
funny idea that we had that went really
really well and it's because the product
even though it was healthy is still a
liquid that wants to be drank by a
consumer who identifies with the
marketing it's like if you just try to
say all right we're gonna make an oat
milk brand that feels you know badass
and rock and roll the oat milk customer
probably isn't guys who ride Harley
Davidsons like they're not drinking oat
milk but you're trying to market to them
so it's like that's probably not gonna
work as well because you've got way more
marketing education to do to try to
convert new customers into something
that they've never drank before water is
different for us because everybody
drinks water we don't have to explain
how to drink water how to use it like
everybody drinks water from Harley dudes
to metal dudes to yoga moms to everybody
and now it's just about from a from a
demographic or psychographic standpoint
who just thinks this is a cool thing
could be a part of their day with you're
not trying to convince them why they
should drink water
right gotcha and so you also went
through science or how did science get
involved because this when I first heard
about this was like oh this is coming
out of science labs is that did you
bring the idea to them did you meet them
and
incubate the idea how did that happen in
this room for people who don't know what
we're talking about science science
science is like this weird quasi venture
capital firm but also like a weird
incubator they launched Dollar Shave
Club and a variety of things or helped
correct weird combo of like company
builder and investor based out of LA yep
yeah so we launched liquid death in a
bit of a backwards way than most I think
beverage brands launched which was we
launched a year before we met science we
launched liquid death on social media
before we ever had product because we
knew that with such a crazy idea like
liquid death there's nobody who's
writing me a check for the idea of
liquid death they're like you're this is
stupid you're crazy like who would ever
buy this it's a negative name it says
that retailers will never carry it yadda
yadda yadda so I knew that I had to
prove it out as a concept on social
first before I could actually make
people feel like I'm D risking this
thing a bit to actually raise so we
designed the can to look like a 3d
realistic can we shot a fifteen hundred
dollar video and then we just put it on
Facebook no Twitter no Instagram just
Facebook we put maybe I don't know three
grand and paid media behind the video
and then cut to three months later we
have more Facebook followers than
Aquafina the video has three million
views we've got a range of DMS from hi I
am a 7-eleven franchisee in the Midwest
how do I get this in my stores or hi I'm
the biggest non out beverage distributor
in New York City called big geyser how
do we talk to a sales representative to
distribute this and we didn't even have
product yet for no idea of how we were
even going to really make it so then I
use all of that social traction and
distributor interest and retailer
interest to then start raising a small
friends and family round so we can
actually produce physical product
because what
the minimums are really really high like
quarter-million cans is the lowest you
can actually produce with a can
manufacturer so it's a little bit
capital intensive just to even start
playing the game how much is a quarter
million a quarter of a million of
product what would that call I mean if
you're just starting what would that
cost I mean it all depends what you're
filling in there but I mean I mean yeah
I mean you're you're talking you know
150 200 250 grand just to like kind of
get started probably doing cans so yeah
once we once we then kind of raised a
little bit we started producing cans we
we bottle or should they be can and
source our water in Austria in the Alps
once we had physical cans that people
let me ask you what does that mean
whenever people are like oh this is you
know spring water from this mountain
it's like you know my head is always
like this is BS what does this mean does
that Matt like phase is true B does that
matter
so like why do you go get your water
from Austria in the Alps like what is
that is that is that branding is that
like is there something about water that
I don't know like why do you have to go
there to get you watered so what I mean
let's be totally honest water for the
most point part I should say for most
people is water yeah like if you had
people try to even even water snobs if
you had them go find taste test Fiji
versus Avion versus whatever can they
really tell the difference
probably not right but I've done this
test many times as an Evian drinker
Evian versus so Evian and Fiji are taste
similar to me Evian versus Crystal
Geyser like it tastes different I've bet
money and I've got it right before but
yeah I think the things that make water
that affect the taste of water are the
natural minerals and how much of them
there are in the water and the pH of the
water is it more acidic
is it more basic and what those minerals
are affect how acidic or how basic it is
so
when you for us our water comes from the
Alps and it literally goes right from
the mountain into the camp
obviously it goes through filters and
things that filter out debris and all
that and then we put it through like a
pasteurization process that makes sure
everything you know it's all clean and
good to go
but everything in that water is that's
the natural mineral profile of the water
that has been built up over probably
hundreds of years in the mountain and
it's like you know naturally alkaline at
7.8 or 7.9 pH it's got a nice mineral
level nice mouthfeel when you're
drinking it because of the level of
minerals so that comes right off that
way it's all everything's natural about
it almost every major water brand in the
US whether that smart water
essentia Aquafina Dasani most of those
brands they're zinc unit is tap from the
that then they reverse osmosis which
strips everything out along all the
natural minerals all the bad stuff
everything so it's literally just like
empty water then they have to add in
minerals back in to kind of make it
taste good
so they'll add in the natural things
that occur in water but just kind of
artificially with just doing it at the
factory to kind of make something that
has a decent pH and a decent mineral
profile that tastes good so those are
kind of the two options when you say
something is spring water
it's very strict from the FDA of what
that has to be like to call it spring
water you cannot alter the original
mineral profile of the water so even if
you take it off the mountain if you put
it through reverse osmosis and it strips
out the natural minerals and you add
them back in you can't call it spring
water anymore because you've altered the
original thing so you know our water
like I said that's kind of how we think
about it everything we have in our water
is natural that's how it comes off the
mountain it's kind of its own perfect
thing we don't have to go through the
whole process of like using municipal
tap water from the factory stripping
everything out adding stuff in and kind
of like creating a
right now that's that's okay and you
know I've never actually had liquid
death is it's flat water though right
it's not sparkling and it's not flavored
we have a sparkling version but we have
a still and a sparkling yeah and as a
you sorry just to sort of finish it so
you you took that you know you've raised
a little bit you do the social media to
prove hey we can build a fun brand that
people resonate with then you figure it
out okay to produce the minimum run I'm
gonna need a couple hundred grand to get
this thing off the ground and you raise
kind of the friends and family round
that was from science or afterwards
science came about and they wrote a
bigger check we raised the friends and
family around just to basically cover
like a super limited you know the
smallest run a product we could do right
and then once I finally had a physical
can of liquid death for the first time
which was probably around October of
2018 we had a guy that we knew who knew
someone at science she said hey you guys
should really talk to science like
they'd probably be all over this so we
went and met with science and brought
them a physical can and once someone
could really hold it and it wasn't just
like us showing digital images from
social it made it way different it's
just like they understood the magic of
it and how cool this would be walking
around with this or how you know how
into this people would be so then we
that's when we kind of decided to do a
deal with science and over the next two
months after that they helped us gear up
our D to C launch where we launched
online in January of last year and do
you think this will be mostly D to C you
think this will be retail how do you
think about that obviously you're doing
both where do you think is the kind of
bulk of the business gonna come from I
think we've always known it was going to
be retail from the beginning we just
didn't know how soon do you start really
pushing into Rico water is something
that you don't want to just order on the
internet like you want to be able to buy
a water when you're thirsty somewhere
right so it's just naturally a retail
play versus like you know something like
maybe like a Soylent it's like a meal
replacement thing you could order those
to your front door because right not
like you just randomly deciding to go
get one of those but now they're pushing
into retail as well what
your pitch on how big this gets and the
way I like these pitches is kind of like
bottoms up so it's like you know rather
than saying you know well vitamin order
sold for this much so maybe we can get
that much or more cuz blah
but like bottoms up being like you know
there's this mini grocery store I don't
know if you think that way but like do
you do you have that sort of analysis of
like I think this gets this big because
I can say that there's this many venues
or this many grocery stores or this much
do you see demand of this so I think we
can you know when we grow up we can
become this big do you think that way or
how do you approach that yeah I think
it's a combination of things I mean one
you can obviously start what is the size
of the bottled water market which in
2019 the bottled water market in the US
alone was twenty billion dollars bottled
water still water made up a little under
fifteen billion of that twenty and
sparkling is about three and a half
billion of that twenty so it's a massive
market and what's the result labored Oh
like private label okay okay yeah and
flavored stuff in there the biggest
retail in terms of doors channel is
convenience stores there's like over a
hundred and fifty thousand convenience
stores and then I think there's maybe I
don't know I think there's maybe thirty
thousand grocery stores or something
like that and then Shenron and on
premise like restaurants and bars
there's about a million in the US so you
can start looking at you know velocities
of what certain water brands do in
convenience stores we can look at some
of our velocities that we're seeing and
what they could grow to and yeah you can
really start to like forecast out how
big this gets but it's like you know
well-performing water brands just in
7/11 can be doing 50 million in sales
just in 7-eleven in scan sales for like
you know you know a decent water brand
and that's just 7-eleven who are the top
three the top water brands in terms of
six scale
are as you can probably imagine like
Aquafina and Dasani they're both over a
billion dollars and it's those are owned
by Nestle and or who those owned by
Pepsi aquafina of Pepsi the Sonia's cook
okay Wow okay
that's and then Nestle's the other big
one Nestle has a couple brands like
Nestle Pure Life and kind of the more
budget value water and yeah they're
another they're over a billion as well
who owns at how owns and how much so
Fiji's owned by wonderful brands they're
down near you in LA right or I don't
know if you're in LA but in LA how much
how much revenue do you think Fiji and
Evian does I think
Fiji's a privately owned company is a
bien public I don't know the exact
numbers I've seen a couple things so I
can't really comment if they're if
they're accurate or not but I assume
that Fiji Evian they're probably
somewhere around like five hundred
million a year something like that I
guess what would the margin on that be
so is it as big as I would think it's
not as big as you think really because
the retailers they want the most margin
on bottled water like they want to mark
out bottled water higher than almost any
other beverage that they have in the
store so the retailer wants a lot of
margin then you've got a distributors
that need their margin so it's like you
really get down it's not like bottled
water and some like insane margin for
suppliers than other products like like
energy drinks probably getting more
margin than water which I think the
conception is dude they're just bottling
water that's like you know you're like
selling air yeah but in reality the
margin is probably I would guess sub you
know sub 30% not above 30% it's kind of
my my guess I think most in most
beverage they say like you know a target
like really solid margin for beverage
would be like 40% that's like 50% is
like you're killing it right and then
it's like I think you get down like 230
is probably like on the low end of so
when I used to own a train a hotdog
stands in Nashville and
when it was really was called southern
Sam sweeteners as big as a baby's arm
and and I would crush it on bottled
water in the daytime bottled water would
cost two or three dollars and at
nighttime when everyone's drunk you
definitely add a little bit more to it I
think from Restaurant Depot I think a
bottled water was 14 cents or like or
good it was like stupid and so I like
the hotdogs would like make a little bit
of money I would make it after you can
make $1,000 a day off bottled water that
was where the money was that was the
bottled water
yeah that's a sales guy you got Sam here
yeah man I was talking water like crazy
that was where I was that we had this
question which was if you had to make a
thousand dollars tomorrow but I stripped
you of all your kind of like current
income streams and your current business
how would you go try to make a thousand
bucks in a week or whatever and I think
Sam's was I go to a hot place I've buy
water for 14 cents and go sell them in
front of a stadium or something like
that in a corner like at the at the
stoplight like yeah because like people
don't care about the water they more so
care about the convenience like a [__]
it's right here it's and I totally over
thought it and I was like well I guess I
would create this online store and I was
like nah it's too slow too complicated
dude I would I would be like a bender
and a like a concert series like the
summer concert series that cities has I
swear to God I would make a thousand
dollars a day in bottled water sales you
just you know that's not every day but
you crush it at those concerts just
selling bottled water that was where I
where I would make a killing what other
opportunities have you seen that if you
weren't starting this business you would
be very interested in like things that
you've discovered along the way there's
two questions right because our audience
the listeners for this right we got
hundreds of thousands of listeners who
are gonna hear this and they're all
entrepreneurial types but really you
know it's not like they're gonna go and
do one of these things but they just
love to hear different perspectives it's
like you are right in the world few of
us even think about on a daily basis so
you're seeing thing wasn't seeing unity
thinking about things that we don't see
which is why you came up with this idea
to begin with and so
they really do love to hear kind of like
you know I've always thought you could
do this I said it doesn't have to be a
great idea it could be a you know I just
noticed that these things really crushes
it or these are kind of backwards I
think it might be fun to try this do you
have anything that that's in that could
complete that sentence yeah I mean that
is a tough one like I mean I guess
obviously like you're always looking for
white space right I think where I was
really inspired most by my point of view
on business and branding is from Bergeon
like Richard Branson what you know early
in my advertising career when I worked
in San Francisco the main account that I
worked on was Virgin America the airline
so I got like super deep into virgin and
and I read you know Richard Branson
books and I just would be loved that
their model was like we go and try to
find a stale category and we make the
one really cool fun brand within that
category where it almost changes the
category where the rest of the category
almost has to start adapting like
Airlines like nobody was excited to get
on an airplane we eat airplane food or
anything and then they were the first
ones to make planes look like neon blue
lighting and like you know TVs in every
seat which now is like a common thing in
every time right so it was like that
really inspired my way of looking at
where I would look for things that were
like what is something that like you
said like cottage cheese like what is
something that is extremely boring or
like what's a category that just nobody
cares about where you can't think of one
cool brand in and obviously like if it's
something that seems like it could still
have appeal it's just a victim of poor
brands not getting it and you know just
not innovating or whatever it might be
and you see an opportunity hey this
actually could be a thing that people
really would love but it's just been
stuck in this like doldrums of branding
for so long that it needs something
because at the end of the day with
especially with packaged goods like
branding is so much more important than
most suppliers or the core companies
think right you know because most
companies are started by business people
in the most part it's like someone with
an MBA someone who understands the nuts
and bolts of building a business it's
rare that businesses are started by
creative people like artists and people
that are you know graphic designers and
stuff like it's it's two different
things and usually what happens is the
business folks think really rationally
like okay my product contains this so
the name of the product should be about
that and I should list all the rational
reasons why someone should buy this yeah
it's like and then that gets them a
certain part of the way but then they
end up hiring a creative agency to get
all these creative thinkers in to build
a story around this boring thing to make
people actually care about so what I
think is interesting is when you have
creative people at the very beginning of
the process where it's like just
considering what the company should be
what the name should be what the product
should even look like will someone even
care about whatever it is you're selling
because I think the creative people do
have a good sense of culturally what's
going on what's cool what do people care
about what's the climate business people
not so much I feel like they're more in
like the nuts and bolts and weaves of
like numbers and affection which is
hugely important which is why there's so
many brands that never get the creative
side but still they just become these
logistical Swiss Army knives that still
get acquired right but it's like just
imagine if they had great creative - you
might be a two billion dollar brand
right you know I'm speaking of water I'm
good friends with this guy Scott
Harrison from charity:water have you
ever met Scott yeah I've never met him
I've ever heard of the brand and so so
you've heard of the brand because I
think they've done a phenomenal job with
the brand and so this is just a like we
were thinking when we're just
brainstorming oh what's another category
in a grocery store that you could do
this which is definitely a totally legit
brainstorm we can do but this is a very
different analogy but I think you did
the same thing so Scott was a party
promoter like you came from a punk-rock
background then ads yeah and you went
into this CPG space which
not that maybe the most conventional
path he's a you know party promoter club
promoter in New York for ten years you
know convincing dudes to buy you know
three thousand bottle and three thousand
dollar bottles of Grey Goose that they
know you know you could go back fifty
dollars across the street to get table
service right and so then he goes and he
you know has a come-to-jesus moment go
goes to act si I'm paid the neck I'm
giving back and but he's all he knows is
how to promote parties all he knows is
cool and so he reinvented charity as a
cool brand and he has this quote he does
when he like tells his story which is
it's a quote from someone talking about
philanthropy and they say man imagine if
we could sell charity with one tenth of
the finesse that brand sell toothpaste
like imagine if we had one tenth of
their marketing power that they do they
use on toothpaste
imagine how much food we could do in the
world and so that's basically what he
did where he was alright I'm gonna make
a brand that actually stands for these
three things and I'm gonna have awesome
design because every charity website
sucks and you know it looks like they
hired their eighth grade cousin till I
build it for them and I'm gonna do these
with influencers I'm gonna do these
print campaigns etc etc and you know
he's now been raising you know over a
hundred fifty million dollars for the
cause he's one of the fastest growing
and best charities out there because he
did what you did which is he applied
cool to a category that was totally
uncool
before ya know totally and I think
there's so many different places where
you can think about you know I think
cool is a weird word because it's like
it can be taken so anyways I think it's
like it's less about cool but it's like
how do you make it interesting or how do
you make it like desirable like I have
to have this writing you know but that's
what I want to know I mean I want to go
back to that first question that Sean
kind of dismissed a little whereas like
what else is in that category because I
think that's that's really that's
intriguing to me I mean our there things
that you've explored or you're like you
know this actually is one of those
categories I'm busy now but that would
be interesting for someone to change
that category I think we're even
thinking about that with liquid
yeah to like I think liquid death you
know is so much bigger than just a water
company like at the end of the day like
I think we think about ourselves as like
a pop culture Factory like we just made
we released a liquid death vinyl record
recently I don't know if you guys saw
that but it was like in less than two
weeks we sold 700 vinyl records which is
like more than most metal bands actually
sell when they release a record on a
major metal label and it was like this
money idea where we took social media
hate comments and made them the lyrics
to this metal album and it's like wow a
water company now just became a record
label for a minute and it's like I think
about all these other places where there
could be innovation that tied our
general mission of like health that's
like do we like what if liquid death
creates like a chain of heavy-metal yoga
studios you know where it's like people
who want to do yoga but they don't want
to listen to Yanni when they're doing it
like is there some room for like some
kind of cool like how do you make it a
totally new you could do like this
experience you could do like tough-guy
multi-vitamins if you need to write a
healthy product multi-vitamins and be
like okay cool actually you know
rainbows and Care Bears like maybe we
could just make this form factor a
little different brand a little
different right to speak to a different
audience who's you know so you you guys
have raised let's say 10 I forget the
number 10 or 12 million dollars you're
not huge yet you're definitely still
getting going how do you decide so like
at my company we have a brand that
people know and people just if we make
stuff people will buy it but in my head
I'm always like I don't want to make
other stuff let's just like focus on
what we're doing and kick ass at that
and then maybe eventually expand whereas
you've done these little experiments
like the vinyl record inmate so maybe
you're also trying to uh maybe you
weren't joking with your heavy metal
yoga thing in my head I'm like no no no
[__] that focus what uh do you have like
a like logistically how do you decide
where to throw a bunch of that and throw
money at in order to so let me ask you
that so this is what I mean all these
other products that we could potentially
make
that actually sell or actually succeed
they double as marketing for the water
yeah this marketing that it's profitable
it's profitable exactly it's like we
made a vinyl record I can't tell you how
many eyeballs that got liquid death on
from people reposting the album sharing
the album talking about it and that
album for us to execute including
printing the vinyl cost us $12,000 and
we've already made do you have work on
that how much stat who worked on it but
you know did you we hired a guy that we
knew that was a friend of a friend who's
an incredible metal musician who wrote
the whole album his name's Gus Rios he
wrote and recorded the whole album his
buddy mixed the whole album and his
buddy mix stuff for Justin Bieber and
all these other guys so we got the whole
album recorded we made a commercial for
maybe 2 grand on stock footage and my
wife edited the video so I was like you
know that's all that's all we launched
with it was a little launch video made
with stock footage and we pressed
records and sold the records in our
merch store and it's like all that stuff
adds together that's why it's like what
would it cost to to start let's call it
a chain of five looks small heavy metal
yoga studios in LA like small little
studios not a lot going on you find some
you know some instructors like maybe you
could actually build that out for call
it 500 grand let's just say like you can
make you could build a 5 change Ogas to
do heavy metal yoga studio chain for a
500 grand
what does 500 gram buy you if you try to
run one TV spot right during the [__]
Oscars like maybe you get a 30-second
spot
and what's gonna see more lifts and
brand evangelism for your brand running
one $500,000 commercial during the
Oscars or building a chain of five heavy
metal yoga studios in LA that gets
talked about by every publication heavy
metal yoga studio launches in their leg
people actually go to it everyone who
goes takes
and stares and talk it's like that's a
wave smarter way to spend your money and
you might actually make some of it back
if it's a good enough business model you
know this is like Elon selling
flamethrowers right yeah he is the you
know sort of iron man trying to be a
badass rockets and you know drilling
into underground and electric sports
cars so he comes out with a flamethrower
for $700 I think it was and he sold
he sold like million shit-ton I think it
was ten millions of dollars and the
whole thing is basically just being like
you know feeding the evangelism like you
said of the cult of you on of yeah life
should be a little more badass we need a
little more fire a little more speed and
a little more like you know rocketry to
in our in our lives and so it's the
brand you know when you curate your own
new experiences or whatever for the
brand you can also control what goes on
there so it all plays yoga studios it's
going to be coolers of liquid death as
the waters act right you know it's like
it all kind of my takeaway from this
whole podcasts is I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do a handful of I'm not gonna launch a
yoga studio but a $12,000 vinyl release
or something like of that scale is super
interesting I need to do more of that do
you have one person on your in your team
who like does these odd things or is
this just like a product like a project
that you lead and coordinate so we work
with you know we do have like creative
agencies that we work with like most of
which are run by my friends who I use I
knew from the industry they've got small
little startups and what's nice about
liquid death is because we want to do
such cool different things people are
willing to kind of work at a nice homey
rate because like they want that thing
up for their real we're not just ask
them to make some you're crazy enough to
be willing you're open enough to like
try that necessary and say hey look at
this amazing thing we did with liquid
death and they want the nestle check not
the liquid death well they're doing the
same thing that you're they're doing
they're doing the same thing what you're
doing with the vinyl they're like maybe
pay for itself but it's also marketing
right
right exactly so yeah I mean we get a
lot of you know smart creative people
that are throwing ideas into the mix but
you know at the end of the day like you
know I'm a very creative focus CEO I
think we built like a nice team around
us that like is really smart with
operations and supply chain and that
kind of stuff it's not so much my strong
suit and I can you know focus more on
the brand and creative side which you
know liquid death it's really a brand
play you know like and that it's so
important and I think building out all
these fun things we're talking about of
like how do you build this brand that
has such an evangelist audience to it
and it continues to grow like that's not
that's really the focus this is great
we're coming up on the hour Sam did you
have anything else you know I'm taking
notes I'm gonna write down you know to
my team and I'm like cuz I have I'm also
creative but I definitely am like
fiscally conservative and I'm like no no
we got to focus and focus on the cash
cow but I'm like you're right this dumb
[__] that seems dumb but it's awesome
you can do that for way cheaper than you
think yeah I guess it's just like always
think like one of my old bosses I used
to work I was the crib director at
vaynermedia so Gary Vaynerchuk was like
not my boss essentially you know I
learned a lot from him in terms of like
marketing is really just about day
trading attention like marketing is all
about attention and it can mission to it
or price the price for a billboard
you're paying so much per eyeballed it
sees it it's like yes it could be
effective but you're overpaying for it
versus create a yoga studio in LA you
might generate even more eyeballs and
attention at a way WAY lower spend I
think it's just always thinking about
who how do I get attention for my brand
and what are all the different possible
ways that you can get attention what's
like the most cost efficient ways to get
that and I have to ask was it awesome or
not awesome working for him is the guy
the real deal or what I love Gary I
think he's like an incredible human
being like you know I've worked for a
lot of corporate
folks and I think there's there's a lot
of egos there's people who don't care
and I think Gary like truly cares like
even if you're gonna tell him you're
you're quitting like he's gonna be like
Oh awesome like do you need any help
finding your next thing you know like
he's just like he cares and I think
that's what he's built his whole company
on is like you can build a massive
company with like a compassionate point
of view on your people and not just
being some like tyrant kind of do you
think there's any anything about Gary
cuz he's a very public presence right
he's personally out there a lot and you
know anytime you personally put yourself
out there because it's putting a part of
you out there not the whole thing is
there anything that either people don't
really know about him or is a
misconception that you've seen about him
is there anything like that I would say
that like just talking like just talking
with him normally one-to-one is
obviously the volume isn't as loud as it
is when he's on camera you know very
like he's an entertainer to a degree
right now he's an educational business
entertainer but he's entertaining to
watch like the way he talks like how his
passion is like how he's smart like
there's plenty of business people who
say smart things but not maybe as many
that are like it's like in a way he's
kind of playing you know a bit of his
character but it's like off camera like
he's way more mellow I would say then
most people think like you know he's I
was on I was I was on his podcast or
like I forget whatever it's called and
he was very nice and I had we he turned
it up slowly but yeah he had he wasn't
on right away yeah he had to get amped a
little that's awesome alright well Mike
we'll wrap it up where should people
follow you find you if they want to hear
more thoughts or slick with death you
know give people shout out where people
can get more of what they got today yeah
I mean most everything happened in with
liquid death is on instagram so follow
us it's at liquid death on Instagram you
know athlete with death on Twitter and
liquid death comms or say and
yeah that's that's it
awesome this is awesome I'm looking at
it right now thanks for taking the time
I'm in this bad ass sorry if my typing
is something you hear on the podcast
kids while he was talking well he was
talking I was like I am to write this
down I had three ideas while you were
talking about exactly what you said but
you inspired something while you were
talking I was like I got to write this
down cuz we're gonna do this and if you
don't do this like I'm gonna regret it
so all these everyone here's typing and
yeah I do the same thing I'm like
looking up everything you're saying
that's a that's a sign of a good podcast
though and it's all about speed like
that's one thing I always push it's like
the idea shelf life these days is very
short they give you have a cool idea
right now you don't make it tomorrow
someone else is probably making it you
know it's like right on guys thank you
thank you so much for coming on all
right thanks guys take care thank you
[Music]
you